こんにちははじめしゃちょーです今日は
とても真面目な動画です
初めしゃちょー
結婚偏差値どれぐらいなの
はい
えー
そろそろやばいです結婚もしたいとかし
たくないとか言い続けながら早くも来年
30を迎えますはじめしゃちょーですあの
比較的顔若い方なのわかりづらいと思うん
ですけどももう30ですよもうすぐでその
コロナが流行って出会いとかもなく
長いこともないですけどないこともない
ですけども出会いが極端に少なくなって
あれこれマジで良いよ結婚できないんじゃ
ないかと思ったこの中東海オンエアの哲也
が結婚したりだとか同世代の人がどんどん
結婚していきあれそろそろ本格的にやばい
んじゃないかと焦りも持ちつつあでもこれ
1人身の方が楽しんじゃないかっていう
独身貴族感みたいなものも徐々に出てきて
正直自分が今
誰だか分かりません結婚したいしたくない
わ置いといて1人の男としてこのはじめ
しゃちょーという人間は結婚に向いてるの
が向いてないのかそういうものをですね
結婚偏差値っていうもので表せるらしいん
ですよあの詳しくないのでわかんないん
ですけども聞いた感じで多分結婚すると
幸せになれるかどうかの偏差値みたいなの
が測れるらしいので具体的にそろそろ結婚
の本題に入りたいと思ってるので実際に
結構偏差値が書かれる方のところへ行って
みたいと思います
真面目な動画になると思うんですけども僕
の将来のことだと思って
是非
生暖かい目で見てみてください行ってき
ます
はいというわけで早速
着きましたこちらの会社になります特別な
許可もらってマスク外させていただきます
ちょっと行ってみますか
失礼します
[音楽]
見てくださいこれ
1年婚活のパートナーエージェントわかり
やすいこの2つの赤い線が結ばれて一つに
なるというなるほど
[音楽]
知らないですけど
ほんとさんと
受付とかもありますね
見てください
[音楽]
するとこういう写真も
撮れるんですねこういうのからモツベアが
あったりするのですごい
これが今結婚したいとなりました
モチベー写真ですこんなの見ちゃったら
結婚したくなっちゃうもん
いいなあ
すごいなもう
[音楽]
快活をここにも
ここはポケモンカードする部屋でしたね
絶対違う
わけなんですけども今回遊びに来たわけで
はなくちょっとほんと真面目に結婚偏差値
っていうものをちょっと
測っていきたいと思いますじゃあスタッフ
の方に話を聞いてみましょうというわけで
今回の僕の結婚を担当してくださる方が
いらっしゃいましたのでちょっとお話聞い
てみたいと思いますお願いします
[音楽]
よろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ますこの後うちのAI今回のアセスメント
を受けていただく
AI婚活のアクセスメントそれを見て
はじめしゃちょーのダメなところといい
ところを出してお話しさせていただければ
なと思ってますじゃあまずはアンケートと
いうかそういう感じなんですねアンケート
みたいに全然簡単なものじゃなくて112
もあります
[音楽]
それを見てお話ししていただくという
わかりましたちょっと進言に答えさせて
いただきますそして112も行ってきます
さあ行きます
スタートこれはすぐこの余裕感じなんだ
ちょっと本当なんかいいように映るとか
考えずに真面目にございます
よし36も終わりましたはいありがとう
ございます結構悩みましたこれ中本だけな
んですけれども
よろしいでしょうか
なる
ほど
許せない方が許せない
うわーやだなー
両方嫌だな
相手に求めることになると急に遅くなり
ますね
自分のことだったらささっといけるんです
けど
[音楽]
やばい地獄の選択が永遠に迫られますね
絶妙なラインをついてくる必要なんですよ
結構ヤバいですねうわーこれは嫌だなって
思うなほんと同じぐらいのレベルが出て
くるんで
自分がそれどっち取るかっていう
皆さんこれどっちが嫌か答えてください
付き合ったり結婚したりした人の行動で嫌
なほうですなるほど自分の気持ちを伝える
のが苦手だったりあなたが嬉しい楽しいと
感じられる趣味は思い出を共有できない何
考えてるかわかんない気持ちが伝わり
にくいのと場の空気を察するのが苦手で
あなたの気持ちの変化に気づかずあなたの
気に触るような言動を取りやすい
ちょっとこれどっちが選ばなきゃいけない
ですかそうですね
楽しいと思ったことが共有できない
何それってことですよねそういうこと
興味ないんだけど
ロビンさんの気持ちの変化に気づかず
なんかもうほんと嫌なこと言ってくる
みたいなですねちょっと
待ってくださいよいやー
校舎ですかねコースが嫌ですか
校舎の方がまだいいかなって感じですあの
共感できないのはきついですよかったねっ
てはいそうですまだKYの方がこっちが
我慢すればあーなるほど
言われ続けるとか
嫌ですなるほど
若干ですけど両方嫌ですけどそういう質問
を
セッションおかしくなる人と共に追加され
てそういうことですからね
終わりました
[音楽]
疲れましたココイチで早いですよ診断の
時間自体はあ本当ですか30分かかって
ないぐらいだと思います
自分はこうしたいみたいなのが明確にある
タイプなんで2択とか早いかもしれない
ですただやっぱ止まる時は止まりますね
考え込んじゃってなかなか考えさせられる
アセスメントでしたねありがとうござい
ます
[音楽]
お願いします
先に結果からいきますかもう出たんですか
上がはじめしゃちょーさんが大事にして
いる価値観で下がお相手のパートナーに
求めている価値観ですなるほどでもうこれ
すごく特徴的なのが色で言うと赤ピンクが
多いと思いますけど大きいですねこれは
言い方ちょっと悪くすると自己中型で
芸能人の方に多い
波形です
なので芸能人の方は結構この赤色でられる
方多いですなるほどなるほどよくも悪く
もって感じですけど
自己中ですねYouTubeも自分の好き
なことやりますっていうくらいもはっきり
自己中だっていう自覚はありますそれを
ちょっと仕事に
落とし込んでますじゃあ多分すごくお仕事
に合ってるんですね今はいであとは特徴的
[音楽]
な整
っていうか自分が求めているものとそう
ですね自分とは付き合いたくないですね
自分たちはいでただ基本的にはこれ3つ
違うのが割と普通なんですよなのでここは
割と一般的な感じではありますただすごく
ちょっと
難しいなと思ったのがお相手にはまず自分
の気持ちに正直であってほしいと思ってる
ことがあったら言ってほしいただ
多分感情的になられるのは嫌なんですよ
思ってること言ってほしいんですけど
ぶち切れるとかじゃなくて
真摯に話したいって感じですね真面目に
相談したいでそれが最後の場の空気を読む
ことにも出てるんですよなので切れずに
落ち着いて穏やかに話し合いをしたいそう
ですねただ嫌なことはそんな中でも言って
ほしいそうですまさにそうです割と高度だ
と思いますそうなんですね
女性に求めてるものが難しいかなっていう
ところがありますだから結婚できないのか
でプラス自分が自己中っていう
絶望的です絶望的に多分近いですけど
そもそも結婚したいですか
じゃあなんかそのこの中で例えばその人と
会う機会が減ったりだとかでもう30近く
てちょっとそういう空気感的に結婚し
なきゃいけないという感覚にあったこと
最近がありますねただ
[音楽]
迷ってますね正直あじゃあいい人がいれば
結婚してって感じですかまさにそういう
感じですあそれ結婚できないですね
できないです
今いい人がいれば結婚できるっても今令和
なのでそれは昭和の時代の話ですあんな
情報とはじめしゃちょー平成までですよね
平成ですね
昭和まで
帰っていただければ
結婚できるかもしれないですね
自分から動かないといけないです
自分から動くなんか昔って地元同士で結婚
とが多いんですよあ僕の地元みんなそう
ですよはい私も地元田舎なので地元同士で
結婚しますもしくは大学の時から
月馬結婚でも職場結婚も今減ってるんです
よ
僕も会社
母以外全員男性ですね例えば
昔だったら誰かと誰かが付き合ってるって
言っても一瞬噂されて終わるじゃないです
かでも今って
TwitterとかLINEとかで拡散さ
れるんですよ写真撮られてあの2人として
たよみたいなだから職場恋愛も嫌がるん
ですよみんなだから今まで自然に出会えて
た出会いが今ないんですよだから
ちゃんと自分から動かないと出会いはない
ですなのでいい人がいればっていうのは
無理です
動くって
ナンパとかですよ
ナンパもありだし今で行くと恋活とか婚活
とかをしないと今結婚できないです
なるほど
動かなきゃいけない時代だってね
その
動くってことを考えた時にはじめしゃ
ちょーってあれですかコミュニケーション
能力自分で低いと思ってる感じですかあの
コミュニケーション
能力ないわけではないんですけど人見知り
というかある程度関係値が築けないと
ちゃんと話せないですね
多分自分から動いやらないといけないって
いう中で人見知りってだいぶマイナスです
よね
そうですね基本
受け身ですね僕あ受け身だと思う今ダメ
ですよ結婚できないです
なるほどもっとがっつかないといけないと
いけないガッツリでも多分普通ぐらいだと
思いますもっとってことですもっとです
えっとちょっと週刊誌とか
大丈夫ですかね
悪いことじゃないですもんね
求めることって今日初めてお会いして普通
にやっぱかっこいいじゃないですか味
ありがとうございますね身長も高いで
さらに
家持ってるじゃないですか
前に持ってます資産がある
確かに大学も国立学術高学歴
昔でいう参考ですよ報酬に高学歴更新長
持ってるものはいいのに
動かないから結婚できないんですよ
動かないスローです僕はじゃあもう多分
ずっとまた39になっても同じこと言って
ますよなんで俺結婚できないんだろう」
って時間だけが残酷に過ぎていきます
なるほどこういった方がいいのですねいい
んですよもし仮に動いてもそうお付き合い
できたとしますねもちろん人参代の半ば
ぐらいがちょっとその結婚を意識してお
付きとかもしてきたんですけどやっぱり
その求める部分が高いので付き合ってくれ
ずに嫌な部分とか
性格のコアな部分って見えてくるじゃない
ですか見えてきてあこの人と結婚すると
多分うまくいかないなと思ってから冷め
ちゃうんですよでもすごく自然なことだと
思います本当ですかそれをトライアント
エラーで繰り返していくしかないってこと
ですかめっちゃエラーしてるんですねじゃ
今してるんですけど基本的にみんないい
女性なんですよ付き合ってきた人は
目的だと思って付き合って別れてもいい人
だったなんて後からちょっと覚えてるん
ですけども女子的じゃないですかはい
自分で言った
本当にその自分の結婚観ずっとこの人と
一緒にいると
引っかかるなっていう部分があって別れ
ちゃうっていうのがどこが引っかかります
かちなみに
今まで別れた方々はそんなに多くないん
ですけど仕事とやっぱり女性と動画を撮影
したりとか
ぶっ飛んだやつとかたまにしちゃうんです
よ
水着のおっぱいが大きい女の人を集め
まくって何かしてるとかそういうので
やっぱりちょっと
向こうの顔が曇ったりすると
仕事として割り切ってもらってるんです
けどやっぱ気になっちゃってとかそれは
女性に気になるって言われてるんですか
基本的に付き合う前に
仕事を最優先にしたいから
口出しして欲しくないって言うんですけど
やっぱりその後からそういうことがあると
ちょっと
機嫌が悪くなるとか
あそれは機嫌が悪くなってるのを察して
るってことですかしますね
言ってくれてないってことですか
モヤモヤしてますね相手はなので多分
アンケートにも確かと言って自分の気持ち
を正直にあることっていうのが大事にして
多分それがあるんでしょうねきっとこれ出
てるのはちょっと最初そこ見たらどうです
かあなたは自分の気持ちに正直ですかと
僕は思ってること言ってほしいから
言ってくれる人じゃないって嫌なんだよね
はっきり言ったらじゃないですかいやそう
なんですよねなんか
多分僕が最初に仕事優先で癖出せするなっ
て言ったから言えなくなっちゃってるん
ですよねそういう言い方もよくないですね
そうですねちょっと高圧的高圧的だし
本当に彼女は何も言えなくなっちゃうと
思います私は多分言うタイプですけど
女性がみんなそうではないのでそうですよ
ね向こうにも考えがありますからね
コミュニケーション能力が低いわけじゃ
なくて言葉が足りてないって感じなのかも
しれないですねやっとしたら今のもなんか
仕事にすごくプライドと誇りを持ってる
から
自分のやりたいようにやりたいってところ
があるからあんまり仕事のことはって言わ
ないと欲しいんだぐらいだったら
女性も受け取り方変わるんじゃないですか
そうですねあとなんか診断で気になること
ありました
相手は
専業主婦の方がいいとか
仕事してる女性がいいとかってあるんです
か
難しいなぁちょっとその時の僕の仕事状況
次第によっても変わると思うんですけど
いや子供がいるいないとかでも変わります
もんね
子供欲しいですか
欲しいです
子供は生まれた時にお相手にはどうやって
ほしいですか
相手がどうしたいかにも合わせたいですね
いいじゃないですかそれめっちゃ素敵
本当ですか
すごく素敵だと思います結婚生活でそう
やって成り立っていくものなのでなんか
そんな
専業主婦がいいとかキャリアウーマン
みたいにいてほしいところないですねあ
じゃあお相手にも自分のしたいようにして
ほしいってことですか
知ってほしいんですけどもそのやっぱ子供
をそこで子育てがなんかうまくいかなかっ
たりしても嫌ですしいやいや専業職やられ
ても嫌なんでなんかお互いの一意になって
バランス取れたらいいなっていう
子育てはどうしたいですか
任せたい自分もやりたいいやけどあんまり
こだわりはないというか
本当にケースバイケースだなと思って状況
で全然違うと思うんですよね一緒に育てる
べきなのかとか
任せるべきなのかとか逆に僕が結構
面倒見た方がいい
ケースもあると思うんでそこはもう本当
状況次第ですねじゃあそれでいいと思い
ますあの例えば
絶対言っちゃダメなワードは
家事手伝うって絶対言っちゃダメですあ僕
がですか
[音楽]
世の中の男性全てに
関わることですけど絶対言っちゃダメです
そうなんだ絶対ダメです
期待させちゃうからです
手伝って奥さんが主体じゃですかもうその
時点でおかしいですよねあーなるほど確か
にだから子育て普段もうお前の子供だろ
うって話になってくるんで補佐役ですもん
ね実はこれも昭和ですなるほど
勉強になりますそれは
[音楽]
めっちゃ読んでますねはいちょっと結構
本気で今回良かったりしていただいて
るって
結婚したいんですねやっぱり僕の中その3
時近くになって綺麗事だけじゃない
結婚っていうものが
周りから得た情報からするといいことも
悪いこともあるように見えてるんでしたい
んですけどそれなら幸せな結婚にしたい
から余計足取りが重くなってる可能性は
あります
離婚はしたくないって感じたくないですね
ああ意外1回ぐらい失敗してもいいみたい
な感じかと思ってました
いやーできれば1人の女性を永遠に愛し
たいですね
なるほどあんなところで多分
ロマンチェストな部分がありました
ありがとうございますできれば結婚したら
そのまま一緒に幸せになりたいです
なるほど他に女性にどう
いうものですかこれはあくまで価値観って
いうものなんですけどいやけど最近で言う
と
仕事してる女性はかっこいいなって思い
ますねなぜですかそれは
自立してるからです
自立してるのはなぜそれが自立した方が
いいんです本当ちょっと言い方悪いんです
けどちょっと
冷めちゃうんですよねなぜか
変な感動ですかねこれって
結構今の
平成男子のノーマルパターンだと思います
めっちゃお金持ってますけど今普通の多分
サラリーマンの方って年収どんどん減っ
てってるんで
自分だけに乗っかからないでって思ってる
人めちゃくちゃ多いんですよなんでそこは
すごく一般的な考え方だと思います
多分今専業主義に何が何でもなりたいって
いう女子も減ってますからねなんか
元カノの話なんですけど一緒にしも
みたいな話まで行ってちょっと距離遠かっ
たんでじゃあ仕事辞めますって向こう側に
なってやめて直前ぐらいに冷めてきちゃっ
たとなんであれこれ向こうやめるとお金
どうなるんだろうやっぱり
奥さんには働いてほしいってことですね
それでいくといやなんか別に
乗っかってくれてもいいんですけどもの彼
のであれば
感じたとか子育てたとか
任せたい部分も増える気はします
そういうと私の知ってる人でもそういうご
夫婦いますよ奥さんの方が稼いでてだから
旦那さんの方が家事結構やってるみたいな
ケースとかだからそこは夫婦の多分やり方
の問題なのでそこは多分その奥さんになる
人に言ったらいいと思いますただもし
万が一このご時世なので何が起きるか
わかんないじゃないですか
病気してYouTube更新できなくなっ
たら死ぬ止まるわけじゃないですかそう
なるとやっぱり奥さん働いてる方がいい
ですよねまあそうですね
僕はいいかなって思います今のところは
なんとなくモヤモヤなって僕の考えが
具現化されたというかなんか言葉化された
気がしましたけど今まで言葉化されて
なかったんですかなんとなく僕こういう
タイプで結婚的なそうだなっていうのが
しっかり今日言っていただいたので腑に
落ちましたでもひょっとしたらじゃあ
誰かに言ってもらう第三者的な存在した方
がいいかもしれないですよねで第三者に
それこそ彼女を判定してもらうとか
終わった方がいいかもしれないですね
自分の気持ちで突っ走って実は全然これと
言ってることと違う相手が出てきちゃった
時に
多分離婚が見えてるかもしれないので1回
立ち止まって冷静に判断してもらった方が
いいかもしれないです
俯瞰した方がいいですよね俯瞰して感じ
ましたちょっと木型さんに言われたことを
胸に刻みつつはい
早速
渋谷のハロウィンに行ってこようと思い
ます頑張ってくださいありがとうござい
ます
[音楽]
というわけで本日はありがとうございまし
たありがとうございました結婚偏差値って
お聞きしてたのでこう50とかその
偏差値
みたいなのが出ると思ったんですけどこう
いう感じなんですねそうなんです具体的な
今日ちょっとお話しした書簡で私が
ちょっと点数付けさせていただいてもいい
ですかお願いします
MAXどれぐらいですか100で一番低い
のが0今回のお願いしますでまず結婚偏差
値でいくと
60点ぐらいあるかなと思いましたあ結構
高いそうなんですよ結婚された後のこと
結構ちゃんと考えてらっしゃったので
ただですよ
婚活偏差値
婚活編成でいくとよく見て5点5点なぜ
ならば結婚はいい人がいればって言ってた
じゃないですかそうですねでも今いい人が
結婚できる時代ではないのでタイムマシン
に乗って昭和に行っていただければできる
と思うんですけど
無理なのでそこの
婚活のやる気が生まれればもっと上がって
いくと思います
婚活に達はこうですなるほどですね
結婚しちゃえば多分60点があるので
大丈夫なんですけどそこに行くまでの
ちょっとギャップが広すぎますねなるほど
ですね
幸せな結婚に向けて頑張ります
ぜひ頑張ってください
改めましたありがとうございました